Podcast in the song, Stefan Tissing, Florentine, oh yeah. So, I did actually, so maybe you want to do the same thing? Ah, I already did, always one step ahead of you, you know. Well, let's see. Let's see if that's the case. Maybe you can put me at your microphone so that I can start synchronization. Oh, that's very clever. Pass out, pass out, pass out. Go. Hello, this is Synchronization. Was it enough? It was very good. Well, so, finally, we could arrange this meeting. And to all the listeners, hello and welcome to the Podcast UFO, the Podcast UFO live from Germany. International, worldwide, especially for our Canadian viewers, listeners, said a very new, listen to us, welcome. Yeah, maybe you found us on the UFO Alien Research Network, the radio station in Canada, where we are playing now, because our name is maybe misleading, maybe misleading. Thanks again to Danny from Canada, who reached out to us and asked us if he could play us on his internet radio. Thank you, Danny, stay curious and always look out to there's more out there in the universe than we can see and hear. So always be cautious. That's the reason why we are doing this podcast in English now, because we want to, of course, it was a matter of time, but we want to reach out to more people, because Germany is not enough. There is no Germany in outer space, I always say. No, there is no German, but there's no English in outer space either. So maybe we should start our own language. Yes. How are you? How are you, Florentine? Good, very good. Always looking out in the world, traveling around, meeting new people. It's very interesting. Thank you very much for coming on and having me. How is the tour going? How is the tour? I heard you were on tour. How is it going, man? Yes, it's very good. Always meeting new peoples and trying to connect and making things happen. And it's very good comfort. Making things happen? Which things are going to happen? Yes, very, very much things, very much fun and meeting all the people for everywhere, in Stuttgart, in Wien, in Bottrop, Bochum and always very good. Thank you. Of course, of course, well, so let's move on to our next question.
So, what do you, do you consider yourself a musician or do you... Of course, of course. Well, so let's move on to our next question.
So, what do you, do you consider yourself a musician or do you consider yourself a singer or even comedian? Yes, a very good question. Many people always ask me that. Well, it wasn't that funny. Maybe the bad audio quality made it funny, but okay, move on. No, it's very good because it's very strange for me, because I'm originally not a singer. So for me being on this Rock and Roll tour is very new, but the people are very good and it's always good taking. And there's always a lot going to happen, I assume, of course. So yeah, you can be sure of that. Shut the fuck up, shut up. So I heard that you have a kind of bad dreams. That's what I heard at least. Can you tell me something about it? Is it like a nightliner thing or do you always dream badly or how does it... No, there's always a... How does it... How does it... No, there's always... No, this is always a dream. No, this is a dream come true for me, because being on the road like this is very exciting for me. So, but you told me it was a podcast about outer space and the universe. Sorry, yeah, sorry. I was just curious how this tour life is going. But anyway, now that this conversation is ,,dreht sich in a circle", I would say, let's talk about outer space. So as we have now Canadian listeners who are interested in outer space, let me tell you, there are a lot of planets and we haven't found all the planets yet. So there's a lot to discover. No, we actually found too many, because with Pluto, we found him and then said, that's not a planet. What are you doing here, get out of here! And now he's out and we need a new planet for Pluto. So aliens, if you're listening, maybe you can have a planet if you want. We can give you Pluto if you want, we don't need him, take it out, you can give us something else. Give us another planet, maybe a planet exchange, you know, as you do in school when you visit another country, maybe we can do that with Pluto, give you Pluto instead. But don't blame us, we told you it's not a planet. No, that was very clear from the beginning. We made the mistake, so you don't have to. It's like a poisoned gift, I assume, because we give you a planet and it turns out it's not a planet. We don't want to be to participate in an international interstellar war. No, it's not a Trojan planet, you know. You hear these things of us humans doing the Trojan things with the animals? No, we never do that with planets, never. There is no Nazi army in the Pluto. No, that's just stories, you know, just television, it's not real. Just legend. Legend. No, no. Well, so now that you know about Pluto, Saturn and Jupiter and Neptune and Uranus are actually planets. They are crazy. Those are planets, yet we don't know what will happen in the future. They're crazy, some of them have rings, some of them are like turned over to the side. Some of them, some people say it's gas, which is crazy because it's also a planet it's always it's it's always a planet it's not gas maybe maybe there's some gas but you know thinking of that i sometimes i think i can trust the media anyway because the pictures they look they look us from the planets there are different colors from when i look up in the sky myself so So I don't think, I think they're lying about the colors and the size of the planets. I think they're half the size. I always thought that maybe the colors are made up because, you know, some of them, some of the planets are green, some of them are red, some of them orange, some of them like the moon, like whitish. So I always thought, yeah, they just want the color palette to be full. This is nonsense. It's like the Power Rangers, so they can sell the whole set of planets, you know, you have a green one and a blue one, and it's crazy because nature doesn't work like that. The Power Rangers also, they're not like historical facts for everybody listening, who didn't know that Power Rangers didn't exist. It's a made up lie by the government. They don't exist like Bluetooth doesn't exist. No, yes. And you know, I've heard last week that light travels with a speed, like it's not instant, it travels with a speed, so we don't know which other colors will arrive in the future from those planets, you know. You could say that the green is just the fastest and the blue is just lacking behind, so we can never really know what colors are really. And we might not know some colors yet. There might arrive colors like ultraviolet is a new color. It came to us very recently and we didn't know about that like 20 years ago. So maybe there are colors coming at our way. So but you know, like aliens have to travel faster than light to get to Earth, and we know that aliens were already visiting Earth. So what colors did they have, the aliens, when so did their colors like arrive after they arrived? So how, what did they look like or is the government just not telling us the truth? Yeah, maybe just black and then 20 years later they were like had like white stripes in the face and you know like we don't know we don't know it's just i don't know it's speculating i guess but um i always thought that maybe we will see them in like five years or so yeah they're already here that's very true Maybe they are already here, but we cannot see them in like five years or so. Yeah, they are already here.
That's very true.
They are already here, but we cannot see them yet because the color.
And last week I saw a post on Facebook where somebody was debunking aliens,
like aliens didn't exist.
Oh, this is always the greatest bullshit.
This is always so funny because they're so stupid, those people,
and those videos are so laughable.
And they said because the aliens, he, it looks like a rubber puppet. Rubber puppet? He actually said... Rubber puppet? He said it looks like a rubber puppet. And I said, no, you stupid... It's just because the light didn't arrive here yet. That's why it looks that way, because there are intergalactic beings that are faster than light. And it's interesting because sound is even slower. It's so slow. Yeah, yes, that's what I'm always saying. Yeah, in five years or so, maybe we see the aliens and they're like moving, they're like shouting at us, but we can't hear anything because the sound hasn't arrived yet. And then like five years later, it's like all the aliens shouting at us because the sound now arrives and it's like, hello! Yeah, but the aliens are already gone. We can just hear them and then we say, yes, we want to answer, but they're already gone, and then it's too late. So it's important. And everyone like shrugs or erschreckt sich, because now the sound and all the hellos from the aliens arrive at once, which is like a wave hitting us in the face, you know. Yeah, so it's very important that we start talking to them now, because our sound is already delayed for them, that we can have a conversation and it's not just one-sided and then 100 years later the other side talks and they're all dead already so it's very complicated but we know it and so we can start talking to them thank you thank you for mentioning that we have to talk and we have to start a conversation because we already started a conversation with like probes like a Voyager and stuff like that who were shot in the air, in the space, in outer space and there's like music and pictures from us, from Hitler, just pictures from Hitler and just music from Black Eyed Peas, I assume. Yeah, that's true, but they could also be fake. But maybe that's true. Media, it's just everything I know. I know, I don't know what's with you, but everything I know is from the media. I know everything from the media, because that's the information source from everyone. And that's like, I know everything and I know nothing, because everything I know is from the media but the media also lies it's like fake news and stuff so i don't really know what to what to know so maybe i don't but how didn't we know that aliens put out the voyager so and the government says that we ourselves put them out and the black eyed peas they say no that's human music but i think if you closely, you can very well hear that this is not human music and maybe it's coming from outer space. Yeah, it's too good to be human music. Let's get it started. Let's get it started. It's such an amazing song. Yeah, it's too good. I got a feeling that tonight's gonna be a good night, that tonight's gonna be, it's like, it's like, like who no human man can write this music because it's so like so awesome and so danceable. It's like music from the future because the aliens already have the future and so they know the music of the future and we just don't understand it. And we don't have the video, because the video arrived like in 1500 and they sent out the music video, but the medieval knights didn't know what it was. And now just the sound is arriving and it's already complicated. But we have the pyramids and they recorded this music video. We just have to decipher it from the pyramids. Yeah, and if you look closely on the internet, you can find some medieval recordings, some footage of medieval knights singing I Got a Feeling in like a medieval version with like their instruments and stuff. Yeah. It's hard to find. I don't know if I can find it yet to maybe post the link in the comments corner, but I think it's out there. They sang I got a feeling, ooh, ooh. Yeah, it's very creepy. In 1500. Yeah, it's creepy. You can't almost believe. But now you said the comments corner. Thank you for all the listeners just to post the comments corner with your comments so we can have a conversation about everybody on Earth, like getting those messages from aliens so we can combine them and maybe look what's going on. Yeah, that would be great if you can send us like pictures of UFOs or maybe if you have a sound or so that's strange or even a picture of an alien that abducted you or something, please provide us the information. And now, when we speak English and stuff, people from Canada can also hear us, so maybe
you can do the information. And now, when we speak English and stuff, people from Canada can also hear us, so maybe you can do the same. So, thank you for tuning in to the podcast UFO. So, yeah, let's see, let's see how it goes. We'd like to have a tour in Canada, to go on tour there maybe, and talk to you guys, a lot of conversation about the aliens. Yeah, because like Canada is like more upwards on earth and when we know the aliens are coming from space, they will reach Canada first because it's more up, you know, it's closer to the top of the planet, so when the aliens will arrive, they will more likely come to Canada than like Germanyany because it's lower so we have a more better chance it's on the globe it's lower look at the globe or i mean look at the maybe it's fake you know maybe the globe is fake but you know the fake could also be fake so it's good you don't know it's very honest question yes i have an honest question because um i believe in aliens i strongly believe in aliens of course no i i know of aliens that's it's not a belief if you know it yeah yeah i i know i know of aliens but um people that know of aliens uh sometimes or often like 90 of them also think that the earth is flat and that the media lies you know so i sometimes don't know what to believe have have i have i to say the earth is flat just because i always i know that there are aliens like where's the boundary where's the front where's the what do i have to say? Where's the... What do I have to say?
It's very difficult, but I think that the flat earth is fake from the government, so they can just make the people look stupid, who also believe in aliens, so they can say you're stupid because you believe in that, but maybe it's true, I don't know. So they are faking the fake so they can say, look the stupids, and so they don't have to believe in aliens and don't have to get out the rubber bullets. So you can't really check it yourself. So I think it's more complicated. Like 9-11, it was actually not 9-11, it was 11-9, but after that they kind of switched it because
it was…
They changed it because it sounded better.
Because it's September, you know.
September is 9 and it's 11th September, so it's 11-9, but they tricked us, they swapped
it so we can't know the truth, so we again have to kind of swap the flat earth around
like a Pfannkuchen pancake yes yes with like with like a syrup from canada you know that's like when you when you put 9-11 on like wingdings the font on a word that there are two towers and a plane.
And I always thought maybe, I don't think that's a coincidence. I think that's a fact, of course, because everyone can try it and everywhere is the same. But maybe it's because the terrorists did it on Wingdings, like planned it, and there is like, they did some birthday cards or so with Wingdings, and then they forgot to switch it over, and then they planned their terrorist attack, and it was still put on Wingdings.
So maybe that was the reason they put it on and then Wingdings gave them the idea, you know?
Yeah.
They put on the possible dates like like a google doodle where
they tried to to figure out what the date the best date is where everyone has time and stuff and maybe that's the reason yeah what i heard is that they couldn't decide for eight nine like eight eleven or nine eleven but in winged things like eight is a rabbit and then it would be like rabbit skyscracraper and they thought like how white how do we get the rabbit like such a big rabbit to to destroy the skyscraper so they just looked and said that's just nonsense that's nonsense and they are not stupid and so they looked like the nine oh it's a plane obviously the plane is better than the rabbit yeah i always and then there is this rumor that they first wanted to do it at seven seven eleven but that's just it was already closed it was stupid seven eleven was already already taken and there was like and there was like a key like a small laden nebenan where they said no you can't do it at 7-11, that would like ruin our business.
So do it some other day.
So I heard, do you know that the Bible was originally written in Wingdings before it was translated to? Yes, I heard this yesterday actually, yes. Yeah, I heard it the day before yesterday, so actually I heard it before you. But it's interesting, because in Wingdings, it's just a cool comic, like Star Wars. But it's also confusing, because it says Moses split the sea, but that's just in Wingdings. It's not actually what it meant. It's just the science. It's not what it means, the science. Ah, okay, yes, yes, yes, yes. Yes, so it could mean something completely different. And Jesus didn't walk above water, Jesus walked through sand or something. Yeah, maybe, we don't know. We don't know. So did Moses split the sea because Jesus was walking on it and he was saying, like, get down. Moses split the bread. Yes, and the fish was walking on it and he was saying like get down moses split the bread yes and the fish was walking on water and he was saying i'm gonna split the bread so twice twice yeah he did also not know that it was recorded like somebody later told moses listen moses i wrote all that down and moses was like come on, that wasn't serious. You didn't really write that down. I wouldn't have walked through sand. I would have walked above water if I knew, if I have known that. And then he said like, oh, but I wrote it in windings and I was like, you walk above water. And Matthew and Lucas were like, no, we already wrote that down and published it like on year zero. And Moses was like, oh, that's you stupid buggers. And he was like very emotional. Yes. Yeah. It's like, why are they called Matthew and Lucas? Like, it sounds like modern, like, you know, Matthew, Lucas and Justin, his best friends. Yeah, they came from the future and they were trying, like, copyright issues because they published it without him knowing. And then he was like, no, change it. And then he wrote the Jewish Bible and I didn't read that. No, no, no. No, it's crazy. It's the worst Bible. It's like a bad sequel. It's like you already know that it's just we do it again and then it's I didn't like it. So back to space, you don't know that much about it. And it's like I'm always sad because I think, yeah, maybe I will never find out what's going on there. It's like, you know, the of course, we found planets and stuff and we abandoned Pluto and There was a lot going on. But I'm always sad that maybe in the next 40 years or so when I'm alive, they will not find out about aliens and they will not find about UFOs and so. Yeah, so we have to tell the aliens to Harry, like, because I'm like slightly overweight, you know, and maybe I don't live as long. So I want the aliens to know that if they come at all to us, like they already did, but if they speak to us, they could do that maybe please like in the next 20 years or so, because it was like really it anger me if I like die tomorrow and then they come and I say, oh, come on, guys, now I was like researching and doing this podcast with you for all those years and now you come, it's it would be stupid. So maybe we could maybe we could like write on the the Black Eyed piece, metal piece, like please hurry up a little bit because like we don't live as long maybe come on guys hurry up i i think they were very disappointed the aliens will be very disappointed to see that the black eyed peas are not the only act and they're not as popular as they might think because they only know songs of black eyed peas and they think it's they look like hitler because they just have the picture Hitler and the music of Black Eyed Peas. It's like they think the human race is like dancing, Hitler's singing, I got a feeling and that's just like a crazy picture of the earth. We have so much more. There's also Stalin and there's also like the Blue Man group and if they see that and if the aliens see the blue men group, they will get like so confused and they will get everything wrong. They look exactly like us, except they are blue and we are green. And that's like, that's interesting. We should have also, we should have also written that on the plate, like, don't mind the blue guys, it's not the real, it's not really blue. We don't look like this. We seriously don't look like this. Like we should have added a picture of them and then write, we don't, we do not look like them. Yeah, and now that you say that you are overweight, I'm also grossly overweightly, and so I hope that I am the first person the alien race sees, because they don't know what people look like. So they see me and they don't think that I'm grossly overweight, they just think, oh, this is a perfectly normal human guy, because I'm the only one they know. And you're not just overweight, you're like very weak. And when they then see like a muscular body guy, then they say, oh, he is too muscular, he's too big.
He's too fat, he's fat.
Yes, because they only know like you, like Step and Tightsie, and they always think like, oh, he's not, he's too blue, he's too big, he's too strong, and they will always have you as like a God person. Yeah, I'm like the default person, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So we should like really, really try not to let the blue man group be the first to be seen because then everybody, the aliens will think like, oh, what about you? You're not blue. You're like ill. We should treat you. Everyone has to say, everyone has to say, oh, of course I'm not blue. And like, it's always this like, you have to apologize. And explain it like all the time. Oh, always explain why you're not blue. So the first thing when aliens come, lock up the blue man group, don't let them out of their blue cave. So lock them up, let's bury them in their blue cave and not in their blue car, whatever. So they cannot get out to the aliens that quickly because you can never lock them up forever. You know that they will get out eventually and they will always come to the top the blue man and so you just have a certain amount of time to meet the aliens when they come so now to today's topic which is of course as you know from the title will the moon crash into the earth yes um so there are some very different theories about that. I don't know if you know them all together, but there's this theory that the moon crushes into the earth at some point. There's this other theory that the moon escapes from the earth. That you know, it's like spinning around faster and faster and someday it's like
whack whack i think it's very dangerous because the moon knew what was going on with pluto that we like said goodbye to pluto and now moon is like oh they're okay if pluto is not good enough like i'm leaving too but we have to make clear that we didn't mean that to the moon just for Pluto so i always always thought pluto was a moon uh like like the second mond uh like and and someday it like spinned around faster and the earth was like no go away and then it's like uh like like you know when you were mean to a guy in class uh when you were young yeah he was like going into the corner like, you know, looking sad and maybe crying and was like further away from class, you know, like with like cyber mobbing nowadays or something like you push him away and he's like in the corner sitting and crying. And that's like Pluto for me always. Yeah. I always thought, you know, we chose the moon we have now and we chose against, we voted against Pluto and he was like at the corner of the solar system. Yeah, but I don't think, don't you think it will make him stronger like Pluto because he will learn his lesson and then came back as a better planet? Yeah, what doesn't kill you as a planet makes you stronger, but then we killed it as a planet, so now it's like it's even weaker.
Yeah, he gets like angry and he's turning really fast and he's spinning like crazy.
Turning red, turning red and going bigger and it's just like Mars now.
And then we will like say, oh, come on, Pluto, that doesn't help.
And he's like very angry then.
But how do we get the moon back? Like we can can't let the moon go because then, like, all the spaceships. Why can't we? Yeah, because the spaceships have to fly further away then to get to moon, and it's a waste. So it would be actually way better. So why do we have to go to moon? We don't have to go to moon. What is on moon that's, like, for interest? Well, because there is, like i shouldn't have said that oh i'm sorry that no no you're right because there's no hidden space station on the moon anyway so we can let him go so there was a cut in the podcast i hope you didn't mind but well it's like we have information that we can share sometimes so So I hope you didn't mind. But, well, it's like we have information that we can
share sometimes, so I hope you understand us, even in Canada. But I heard you very polite, so
do not let disturb yourself from the cuts. And even so, thank you for listening to us,
even though we have a bad German accent, but I hope it's fine. I hope you can understand us. It's our first English episode, so don't be that hard on us. Yeah, thank you, Canada, for listening to us and making this happen. And the problem is that we only have German commercials, so maybe you can also buy them, but also it's because German. So please, so they don't think that it's wasted. Now that you have said that here you are some of our German sponsors. Knäckebrot! Wir lieben Knäckebrot! So that was the first sponsor. Das Schmetterlingshaus in Wien. Gehen Sie hin und sehen Sie Schmetterlinge in Wien. Das Schmetterlingshaus in Wien.
Schöne Schmetterlinge, die schmettern sich weg.
Schöne, saftige Schmetterlinge, gelb, blau, rot, grün, alles da, Schmetterlinge.
Riesendinger, kleine Dinger, Riesen...
Keine Raupen, ich wiederhole, keine Raupen, ausschliesslich Schmetterlinger, Wiesen! Keine Raupen! Ich wiederhole, keine Raupen! Ausschliesslich Schmetterlinge! soon to Vienna anyway and look where the aliens are there, because they are everywhere. Yeah, they are everywhere. So back to the topic, the main topic, the Moon. I don't know what to believe. I think it's maybe going away, maybe it's coming nearer. I really have no clue whatsoever, maybe it just stays the same as it did for like a million years or so. It was so funny when the new year arrived, like 2019, some people on Twitter, like a lot of people posted like, Happy birthday, Earth, happy birthday, I can't believe you're 2019 now, you look still as young as ever. I thought it was like hilarious, because they don't know that the Earth is much older. Yeah, but is the moon like younger or older than Earth? Is it like a small brother? That's because it's funny, because the moon is 2019 and they thought like the Earth is just 2019, but that's just like total nonsense. But like, you know, it's because of gravity and the more you weigh, the more gravity you have. So we just have to get more big as Earth to have more gravity on moon to get him closer. So he doesn't get away. It's like if you have like somebody in your flat and you don't want him to leave, so you get very fat to be in the doorway and then you can't get out. Like the song, don't, who's the singer who has the honey on head? The honey on the head? Who's the bald singer with the honey on head? He has like the music video with the honey on his head. What's he called like? It's like the technology guy, Ayo technology guy. Milo. Milo. He also, it's like true, it's a true story. I learned it the day before yesterday, last week. I learned it four weeks ago. Okay. So he has like a song where he goes like, is that like a love song? And he goes like, I love you so much, I want to grow so fat that you can you can move away and he's like it's a very creepy song if you listen closely but it's like make like a very love song and he's like oh i love you so much i want to like chain you up in my cellar it's very weird and he has all these metaphors for love that if you look closely it's just like a confession and like nobody really understands it that way. It's like, oh, what a lovely love song. But he's like, I love you so much that I want to eat your feet off so you can't run away. And everybody's like, oh, he's so romantic, but actually he should go to court way to get his credit card removed. Yeah, that's the second topic of today. It's like Milo's hidden messengers. That's the reason why I'm grossly overweight, is because I want to get the moon back. And this is not something I do out of joy or something because I love to eat or I love Kaiserschmarrn. It's just because I want the moon back. And we as a earth, we as a people, we as a whole have to grow bigger and fatter. Yeah, that's very important because, you know, if only and you really gained a lot of weight, you were really getting out of hand there. And but if you are only fat and then like the earth is spinning around, around it gets like wobbly because like you are this big fat piece of shit uh on on the like one point and the earth spins and it's getting out of sync and like throwing itself out of the atmosphere no that's because we have to always like move around earth yes as a people as a whole um like they did uh further when there was home, like when there were Nomaden, they turned around the Earth, they had no like place where they stayed all the time, and that was just because they wanted to have, they wanted to, you know, like regulate where the moon is at. Yeah, and they always... The moon is always like a Nachtlampe. Yeah, because it's always day, like if you keep walking, it stays day, you know, because you walk and the earth turns under you, you just walk in daylight all the time. It's no night anymore for you. It's like so funny. It's like so, so funny. No, it's like sad because you get sunburned. Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's like sad. But if you walk the other way around, it's always night or like half day long. Do you like, can you imagine that there is like an alien race who gets also sunburned? Like we as a civilization have developed so much technology. We were like developing all the time and it's like we achieved so much, but we still get sunburned. It's like it doesn't make really doesn't really make sense where's the genetics at like that we can't can't get i know that we can't get aids anymore or like in like 10 years or so or 10 days but because there's some some research going on yeah actually i heard in eight days that's why i heard and but but sunburns are still a problem a big problem um so i was like i don't know what's with you in canada but here in germany it's like a big big problem um at the beaches of aussie and nazi and um so i don't know i always thought it was funny like imagining races who have, like, developed light speed and interstellar, like, spaceships, but they still get sunburned because that's a problem you can't solve as a race. Maybe that's the reason why they don't show themselves, because they don't want to get sunburned. And we have to, like maybe we can write on the metal plate, like we have lotion, like come and get lotion before you come, like send that into space with them because they don't have the sun. And it's actually worse in Canada, because in Canada there is always snow, like white snow on earth, so it reflects the sun, so you don't just get sunburn from topside, also downside gets burned from up down, you're weak, you're helpless because you can't cream up downside and you just get everywhere. It's like a sausage that's rotating in an oven. Yeah, it's like the real space race. You know, space race is like not who gets further and stuff, it's just like who gets the best sun lotion. That's the real space race. Maybe they have like an opposite sun where you get like not red, but like it's a cold sun, you know, maybe, and they don't have that. I heard that, that's why actually 9-11, it was under the tower, there was a cold sun, so it sucked it in, but maybe it's fake, I don't know. It could be... Yeah, we don't know yeah that's the reason yeah we we don't know yet it was like actually i think yesterday i actually saw an ufo on the sky oh yeah i saw 40 yesterday okay well let me tell you mine first it was like it looked like a big ball it was like round and it was it looked like Like, you know, there was like, it looked like a big ball, it was like round and it was, it looked like, you know, there was like something written on it, like there was Autohaus Grübner written on it, on the ball and I was like, oh, that's like, I have to make a photocopy of it. So I get out the photo machine and I did it and it wasn't like enough electricity. And I was like, oh, that's strange. Where did all the electricity go? And so I think that UFO is responsible for taking it out, you know? Yeah. So it's like a stealth mechanism for not getting like a photocopy of it. So I was looking right at it and my eyes start to hurt. And like I just got and I bought a new car because I thought it's like the prices are like so low and I always have to recharge so I get it now. So yeah, so it's real. They are already here maybe. They are already here. Yeah, I saw one yesterday too where it's was like, it was like very slowly moving. It was a big, like long, long but round kind of thing. And there was like a big message like Zot-Sahne-Yoghurt, big written on it, Zot-Sahne-Yoghurt. And I was like looking at it, but I couldn't, like it was so slow. And I was like so glad that i can finally take a picture but like it's my hand my handy was like uh empty yeah it died because there was no akku left yes so and i was like wow this is so this is so clever of them like they put your phone down and i thought wow that's so amazing and i turned to neighbor and I said, there's an alien spaceship above the Kölner Dom.
Can you maybe take a picture of it? And he was like, are you crazy? There is no spaceship. And it's like, you know, yeah, it's always the same. Yeah, it's so lustig and stupid, but it's always like, it's always the same, you know, with those people. I don't know, maybe it's like spaceship waves that hit some people, like the stupid people, that they can't see it or so. I don't know. I don't know. We don't know. Yeah, it's like yesterday I was just waking up and I was stepping outside of the tour bus and there was like a UFO like right in front of me. It was like on the ground. It had like like six feet it was walking on the ground and i was like wow did they land already and i was saying to my co singer songwriter i would say listen he listened to the music it's crawling on the floor and he was like um there was like a piece of glass between us so he couldn't hear hear me. And I was like, wow, how did the aliens do that? Like, I couldn't communicate, I was like shut down. It was like, I couldn't talk. And then I was turning around and the UFO had already flown away. And I was like mind boggled because like it's, how do they do that all the time, you know? Yeah, I was like flab flabbergasted yeah like bamboozled me right in the face yeah it's so bamboozled
you're so bam bam bam bam bam bam bam when you see stuff like that it's always so mind
mind boggling wobbly wobbling but it's for us it's normal like normal people wouldn't see it
but for us it's normal we know it and so I think we can get there first because we are the most advanced of the
humans on Earth.
Mewhens.
So we can get there.
So we can get there, yeah.
I think it's very important for us to like get together, like outside Canada, so we
can get like as a human race, like together, because zusammen is one of the strongest,
as is the famous German saying. Yeah, that's very true. So, um, very good that in Canada now we are getting, like, to listen. So we all also want to listen, like what others have say. And so we can, like, connect up with everybody we can connect up with everybody. That's very important because like ,,viele Augen sehen mehr", it's like we say, so we can have an interglobal connection with everybody. Yeah, I'm so sorry. It's like... So, yeah, well, of course, we as human race have to work together, and so we have to, like, every country needs something to throw in the ring, you know. Like, Canada needs everyone, like, we can't achieve something if we are each on our own, because Canada has some strength in, you know, specific topics, and we as a German species have, like, special strength. So everyone has to participate with each individual strength and then we can, you know, like come further as a human race. Yeah, because, you know, because we always like talk about aliens, but we never talk about like Burman aliens, like we don't talk about the city out of alien land they are after, you know, it's like we see other species as one alien civilization, everybody, and we don't humans see ourselves as that, because we have to connect first. Like, let's say an alien comes to town and you're like where you're from and he's like plan name of the planet and not the name of the country you know so there's no there are no germans on the alien country it's just one civilization and maybe they say like oh they are just too split up so we don't meet i think we have to connect it and i think an internet radio is the perfect way to do it and because like on an internet radio you have like the best things out of internet and radio like it's everywhere like radio and it's like like easily accessible like internet so it's both there we have to work together and you have to you you always can start a podcast like us um because we have to make the human race aware and because we have to work together so like we say in Germany hopfen malz verloren it's like we have to work together as as one so but but what do we make the humans aware of again what Excuse me? What are we trying to make the humans away? Wir müssen zusammenarbeiten als eine. Aber was machen wir die Menschen wieder bewusst? Was, Entschuldigung? Was versuchen wir die Menschen bewusst? Dass es Alien gibt. Ja, eine. Und da muss man auch, wir müssen nicht eine Mücke's the main thing, open our minds and be open for things we don't know. And yeah, we have to gather information about the alien race. Yes, very important. Because they are better than us. It's because they are here. We are not there, they are here. Or maybe we are there, but we don't know. But they are here, so they achieved something we haven't yet. Yeah, it's very important to open your mind, but then close it again after you are done. Don't let it be open. Open it, get through it, and then close it behind you so nothing gets in. So you shouldn already, you don't, you shouldn't leave your mind open, like all the time, like just close it at night or something. So something doesn't come in. So we also have like, it's actually very impolite of aliens to not invite us when we invite them. So like we are inviting them for a hundred years now, and they don't say anything.
Like, maybe... No, it's like, yeah.
It's like, maybe we should give them the cold shoulder, like we say in Germany, like, to, like, make them to, like, neck them, maybe.
I was at, like, the day before yesterday, I was, like, at a seminar because I'm very lonely and I don't have a girlfriend.
So, I was at a seminar and the guy, he was, like, very smelling good. good, and he like said that if you want to get a girl, you have to insult it. So that was very, that made sense to me. So maybe for the aliens to recognize us, we have to insult them, like to nag them, to give them like a rüffel, for them to be able to to have interest in us again maybe they lost interest maybe we should stop watching you know forget what i said 10 minutes ago so just like stop watching it's like a bit embarrassing if you think about when you were with the cool guys in school and you turned over and there was like this victim victim kind of classmate watching you the whole time and he's like underdeveloped and stuff and you like turn back and you think weird he just watched us the whole time how creepy is that you know and it's like you know imagine like we with a with our big like uh like uh fanglas in our hands uh watching the night sky with our with our telescopes, and we see the aliens, like, when we watch them, and they suddenly watch rüber, rüber to us, and they see us, and we're, like, watching them the whole time, how creepy would that be? And it's like, we want them too much, you know what I mean? It's like when you want to have a girlfriend, I don't have a girlfriend, I don't know what I'm talking about,
but if you want to have a girlfriend, you can't want her that much. You can show her that you want her that much. It's like you seem desperate. Oh, my food. Wait a minute, my food or a farmer. One minute. Oh, don't open the door. Steppen, don't. It it's the government probably they try to shut down you Steppen, oh My god, I hope he doesn't get shot now by the government or like a potion of the truth potion like he talks everything wrong now Don't eat the food Steppen, Steppen listen to me don't eat, it's government time! The government, don't eat the food, it's from the government maybe. I know, I know, I was just abducted by some alien creature with a, who had a, it's like, you know, and it's like a common species, an alien species that is still on earth, it's like they have this big pink cubes on their back and they're driving on these crazy things. It's pretty crazy. But I'm safe now. He gave me a paper bag, but I'm safe. Yes, that's very good. I won't eat it. I gave him the Euro, the German currency. but so that's peace that there's peace and and there is no interstellar war going on. But did you give it like heads up or tails up to it? Tails up. Yeah, that's very important, because they know if you get it heads up, then they know that you know. So they don't know. They know that I know, but they don't know that I don't know. No, because then they know, ah, you won't tell us to the government, so they know you're safe. Yeah, so maybe the best advice we can give you is don't know nothing. Don't read anything or don't get information through the media, because when you don't know, you don't have to fake you don't know, like you actually don't know. So the aliens can't, you know, when you don't know nothing, the aliens, like, they lose interest in you. Yeah, like the people that don't know, like the so-called intellectuals, like I don't consider myself an intellectual. So because… No, I don't consider myself an intellectual either. Yeah. So when, like, the aliens come, the intellectual will, like, shoot them in the face, you know, and the aliens know that and they say, oh, listen, we don't go to the intellectual types because they will shoot us right in the face, like in our eyes, how many we have, like they have enough bullets for all the eyes. For all the 80 eyes? Yes, they have enough, we counted, they have like bombs for eyes, so they will always go to people like that are not that smart and so they don't know that they will shoot right in the face like the moment they start talking in the face so they will always look for people that don't know that much because so then they would say what are you because intellectual people know you're an alien shoot in the eyes very soon yeah so very suddenly shoot in the eyes dead and it's like and then like the time for us comes. As you say in Germany, and Blindes Hund findet auch mal ein Korn, it's like, then our time comes. Like when you don't know nothing, maybe you survive at the end. Yeah, that's very true. So I try to unlearn everything I have learned, like the day before yesterday. I was like, try to read a book, like, but like in reverse, like to outread it of myself. It was a book about things I knew already. So I tried to like look it backwards up so I just get it, the like listen back into the book. So it's not in my brain anymore. So it can't hurt me. But it didn't work. It can't hurt you. So, but thank you very much to our listeners, because this was a special episode for us. And yeah, we hope you liked it. You know, you like you, you hope you learned something. Be open minded, look at the night sky and think about it. And you have to think, you know, what is going on in there? Yeah, and a special very thank you to all the Canadian listeners, a big Messlethor for all the Canadians. Say we are new now for you, you can hear us and we hope you come back next time when we like explore universe together and write what you think too in the commentarspalte so we can have like a conversation over the ocean, Atlantic Ocean. Yeah, the Atlantic connection has to be has to get stronger uh because you don't know stuff we know in germany about uh spaceships and stuff so yeah yes let's connect and let's uh get in the loop so thank you very much and now we will like start and but don't be afraid it's like it's not real it's just no's not real. It's just us making the sound of a UFO, as we imagined a UFO would sound. But yeah, maybe if you are anxious, maybe turn off now. Yes, we will give you a moment to turn off. And if you're an alien, don't please be offended by it. It's not an actual... We're not actually coming into your airspace we just it's just
an entertainment project and an information project maybe we don't have to do it do we
have to do it yeah we have to do it we have to do it okay okay good so so now please don't say Wir heben ab!